bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro deux tim hague depuis sa
création saint-quentin-en-yvelines
attache une importance fondamentale à
l'accès à la culture pour tous
médiathèque salle de spectacle ou encore
grand événement saint quentin en
yvelines ce n'est pas seulement une
formidable réussite économique
c'est également un lieu d'échangé et de
partage je vous propose donc aujourd'hui
de partir à la découverte de tous les
endroits et de toutes les personnes qui
font battre au quotidien le coeur de
l'agglomération
c'est parti
et
saint quentin en yvelines c'est un
patrimoine culturel riche et atypique où
se mêlent subtilement tradition et
modernité
ce qui a valu à l'agglomération
d'obtenir le label villes et pays d'art
et d'histoire
nous sommes la première ville nouvelle à
pouvoir nous prévaloir de ce label ville
d'art et d'histoire qui était décerné
par le ministère de la culture en 2006
et qui atteste à la fois de la qualité
de notre patrimoine et de notre
détermination à le défendre à le
défendre et à l'enrichir l'ambition de
l'agglomération et de garantir une
répartition cohérente des moyens de
diffusion du savoir et du divertissement
afin que chacun puisse en profiter
ce qui implique d'aller au devant du
public au travers par exemple d'ateliers
itinérants comme c'est le cas pour deux
thématiques incontournables à saint
quentin en yvelines les sciences et la
poésie
si j'avais zappé lui auparavant comme on
me prend j'aurai réussi
les personnes ne m'avait enseigné la
technique ça consiste à montrer que la
poésie est vivante et qu'elle est faite
pour tous à travers la parole des poètes
directement ou des comédiens ou des
expositions que l'on pourra montrer un
petit peu partis sauf territoire auprès
d'eux auprès des équipements tels que
les médiathèques bien entendu mais aussi
des clés des salles de spectacles qui
vous viennent d'accueillir avec lesquels
on pourra partager une partie de la
programmation
l'un des exemples les plus parlants de
la culture de réseau à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines demeure sans
nul doute ses médiathèques sept
établissements répartis sur toute
l'agglomération qui met à disposition
plus de 500 mille documents
c'est pour moi un formidable outil
développement sur le territoire de la
lecture publique qui
et avec un rayonnement sur toutes les
communes de l'agglomération
côté chiffres à population équivalente
nous sommes vraiment au dessus des
moyennes nationales
pour vous donner une idée on peut
notamment souligné que le territoire
saint quentinois contre 25%
d'emprunteurs contre 11% en moyenne
nationale
le réseau des médiathèques et obtenu le
grand prix livres hebdo pour la
cohérence de sa politique tournée vers
l'usager tout est fait pour faciliter
l'accès aux services du réseau
la preuve avec cet outil en ligne ea
médiathèque moderne et ultra pratique
qui permet par exemple de vérifier la
disponibilité d'un document voyez plutôt
moi qui suis un inconditionnel de marcel
pagnol
il me suffit de taper marcel pagnol dans
l'onglet recherche pour voir apparaître
plusieurs suggestions des ouvrages
voyons voir essayons le château de ma
mère
alors qu'est ce que ça dit disponible à
magny les hameaux et non disponibles à
elancourt ok c'est clair et en plus si
je veux je peux le réserver condition
d'avoir un compte
c'est gratuit et pour en ouvrir un il me
suffit de cliquer ici et de suivre les
indications
et pour ceux qui ne pourraient pas se
rendre dans l'une des sept médiathèques
du réseau
l'agglomération a mis en place un
bibliobus pour réserver un livre c'est
très simple il suffit d'appeler ce
numéro les horaires de son passage sont
disponibles deviner
sur i média thèque amis trappistes
veuillez noter que le passage du
bibliobus s'intensifie sur votre commune
suite à la fermeture de la médiathèque
jean jaurès pas de véritable politique
culturelle sans programmation cette
année la saison est placée sous le signe
des arts et du numérique
arts plastiques spectacle vivant vidéo
il y en a pour tous les goûts et dans
toutes les structures on se posait la
question de savoir aujourd'hui qu'est-ce
qui pouvait intéresser l'ensemble de ces
disciplines qui sont à plus innovantes
parce que 50 ans ni vie a toujours été
un lieu où la culture était une source
d'innovation et
le rapport entre art et numérique nous a
semblé évident parce qu'on pense
qu'aujourd'hui la relation entre art et
numérique est extrêmement importante et
innovante et permet de montrer des
choses qui n'ont jamais été vus sur
territoire et pour sortir en famille ou
entre amis vous pouvez également jouer
la carte signer à votre disposition le
multiplexe ugc quelques minutes à pied
de la gare de saint quentin en yvelines
mais également trois cinémas de quartier
le grenier à sel attrape la salle
jacques brel à montigny le bretonneux et
le ciné 7 à elancourt
toujours dans un esprit de proximité
avec le public 12 salles de spectacles
sont disséminés sur tout le territoire
parmi lesquels deux salle intercommunale
le prisme et la scène national de saint
quentin en yvelines qui collabore au
travers de leur programmation et
d'action culturelle sur la thématique de
la danse car oui saint quentin en
yvelines
c'est aussi un territoire de danseurs je
pense que cette cette entité cette
présence de la vente sur ce territoire à
travers ces deux équipements notamment
est quelque chose de oued important est
de quasiment historique pour une ville
qui est
relativement jeune je pense qu'il ya
effectivement une adn d'une histoire
veiller à la ville mais en tout cas on
peut dire qu'il ya véritablement du
public dans nos salles de spectacles sur
la danse c'est
voilà au prisme comme au théâtre de
saint quentin alors que le public dans
les spectacles de danse et le public qui
vient le moins le moins facilement un
salon le race en patinant sur la musique
facilement sur le théâtre / la danse ou
moins facile
or à saint quentin en yvelines c'est
quelque chose qui est tout à fait
probant cette volonté que qu'elle lui
l'agglomération de saint quentin de
communiquer autour de ces deux
programmes cas d'un programme commun
c'est aussi une façon de montrer que
l'agglomération c'est un tout ce n'est
pas uniquement un regroupement de cette
ville et bientôt un peu plus mais c'est
aussi une agglomération qui se pratique
culturellement et artistique en tout cas
pour nous c'est très porteur pour nos
incité véritablement à aller vers de la
qualité vers de la richesse de
partenariat pour aux services à la
population
29 spectacles sont proposés par les deux
structures dans le cadre de cette
programmation commune des artistes à
découvrir mais également de grands noms
de la danse contemporaine comme angel un
prêt gelos cage ou bâches amman les
pieds et n'oublions pas les plus jeunes
qu'il soit en primaire au collège ou au
lycée
les saint quentinois monte sur scène aux
côtés des pros dans le cadre de
nombreuses actions culturelles
mais il leur arrive aussi comme tout le
monde d'aller voir un spectacle
cette année encore la saison s'annonce
riche en émotions 80 spectacles il y en
a pour tous les âges
vous l'avez compris saint quentin en
yvelines c'est la culture pour tous avec
un grand c et ce n'est pas prêt de
s'arrêter
c'est une ambition culturelle c'est une
culture qui va au contact des habitants
et c'est une culture dynamique
résolument tourné vers l'avenir
voilà c'est fini pour aujourd'hui mais
pas d'inquiétude ce qu'imad revient très
vite pour un nouveau numéro 10 il
apporter du bien ciao bye